launch complex 40. it stands about 229
feet
or 70 meters tall which is a little
bigger than the wingspan of a 747
airplane
the bottom two thirds of the vehicle is
what we call the first stage
as i mentioned earlier it will be taking
flight for the seventh time today
the first stage is responsible for
accelerating the vehicle all the way
through
to the edge of space where it will drop
off the second stage along with the
payload
once the drop drop-off is complete we'll
attempt to recover that first stage on
our drone ship
just read the instructions which you see
there on your screen
which is currently positioned out in the
atlantic ocean
if we stick the landing today it will
mark our 69th
successful booster recovery about two
and a half minutes into flight
the first and second stage will separate
and the second stage will ignite its
single merlin vacuum or mvac engine
to carry the sxm7 satellite to a highly
elliptical orbit
separation from second stage will occur
about 4 000 kilometers above earth
and then the satellite will perform
burns to raise its position to enter a
circular
medium earth orbit or neo and reach an
apogee of about
twenty thousand two hundred kilometers
above earth
at the top of your screen there you can
see a nose cone shaped object that sits
atop the vehicle that's the payload
fairing and housed inside there
is the sxm7 satellite the fairing
measures 17 feet or about 5 meters in
diameter
and about 43 feet or 13 meters tall
the payload fairing protects the
satellite from aerodynamic heating
loads and contamination during ascent
once we get into the vacuum of space the
payload will no longer need that
protection
so we'll jettison the fairing halves to
save some weight as the second stage
continues on with the satellite to its
targeted drop
off orbit the fairing halves that you
see there
we use them on a previous mission this
is the second time that they are being
flown
both halves previously supported the k
milsat 1 mission back in july
earlier this year due to upgrades on our
recovery vessel mischief
we'll retrieve one of the fairing halves
with our recovery vessel go searcher
and then attempt to catch the other half
using our recovery vessel
ms tree the large trust structure that
you see
on the pad next to falcon 9 is called
the transporter erector or te
the te is used to roll out falcon 9 from
the hanger to the launch pad
and then raise falcon 9 to its vertical
launch position the te also route power
fluids and content and communication to
both the rocket and satellite
so now that we've gone over some of the
hardware that's essential to
executing this launch let's take a
closer look at today's payload
weighing in at almost 7 000 kilograms
and over 100 feet long when its solar
rays are completely deployed
the 27 foot tall sxm7 built on maxar's
1300 class platform
is designed to provide service for more
than 15 years
this satellite's unique design also
features a large
unfurlable s-band reflector to broadcast
audio and data signals to users on the
ground
by joining series xm's already active
fleet
the sxm7 will deliver the highest power
density of
any commercial satellite on orbit this
new satellite will send more than 8 000
watts of content to the continental
united
states canada puerto rico and the
caribbean
which in turn provides users with better
signal quality and broader reach
now as the count can as the clock
continues to count down we're
approaching
uh t minus seven minutes and 45 seconds
we're looking forward to an on time
liftoff let's take a moment now to learn
a little bit more
about sxf sxm7
[Music]
now
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
prior to the start of our webcast our
falcon 9 team performed functional
checkouts for the sxm7 satellite
at t-minus 38 minutes the team concluded
their electronic go
no-go poll and gave the ok to proceed
into propellant load
and launch to keep both stages of the
vehicle cooled
as much as possible close to launch the
team at the
team at cape canaveral began loading
propellant at t minus 35 minutes
since the second stage merlin engine is
very similar to the first stage merlin
engines
both the first and second stages get to
use the same propellants
our fuel is a refined form of kerosene
known as
rocket propellant one or rp1 and our
oxidizer
is super chilled liquid oxygen locks we
chill the liquid oxygen to be as cold
as we can get it which allows us to load
more locks and
makes it super dense with oxygen
molecules both of these things give us
better performance with those merlin
engines
this also helps us to avoid the need to
continue topping off
prior to launch in order to make up for
losses due to boiling
now at this point second stage is fully
loaded
with rp1 and the first stage looks like
it is complete as well also at this
point in time
liquid oxygen is being loaded onto
both the first and second stages we're
also loading helium into the storage
vessels
on the first and second stages during
flight we passed this cold helium
through heat exchangers on the merlin
engines
the heat of the gas generator exhaust
turns that cold helium into hot helium
therefore expanding it that expanded to
me that expanded helium gas is then used
to fill the empty volume
in the tanks created by the engine pumps
that pull the propellant out of the
stage
very shortly we'll open the pre-valves
between
the first stage engines and the
propellant tanks
we started to do engine chilling you
might have heard that called a couple
minutes ago around t
minus seven minutes uh this basically by
opening those
those valves we allow some of that super
cool liquid oxygen to flow into the
turbo pumps
which helps us to avoid any thermal
shocks that might occur
when we start those pumps up at t minus
two seconds
to light the merlin engines
and it looks like we got some strong
back uh transporter erector
action there slightly moving backward
away from the rocket
so we're currently at just under t minus
four minutes everything appears to be on
track
for our on time launch the range is
green and as for weather
we've been keeping an eye on those upper
altitude winds today
but right now everything is looking
favorable
if for some reason we have to call a
hold on today's launch we have a backup
opportunity tomorrow
with a lift off time scheduled for about
the same time
but as for now all systems continue to
be go for a lift off at 12
55 pm eastern
so first stage fuel loading completed on
time around t
minus six minutes and we're currently
waiting for
uh that first stage locks load to
complete you should be hearing the
callout
call out for that any moment
and second stage liquid oxygen loading
will complete around t
minus two minutes
just a minute before liftoff you'll hear
the announcement that falcon 9
is in startup this announcement means
that the rockets own
internal computers are now controlling
the launch countdown
on falcon 9. once the engines are
confirmed to be at full power
the flight computer on the second stage
will then command the ground hold down
to release the rocket right at t0
our satellite team continues to monitor
the health and status of that sxm7
satellite
located there in the fairing that you
see on your screen
currently all systems are go on the
[Music]
satellite
the range continues to be green for
launch and weather continues to look
good
[Music]
[Music]
uh
hold hold hold on the primary countdown
as you just heard we did hear a hold
hold hold called out today the clock is
stopped at t minus 30 seconds
we're gonna check in with the teams give
us a moment and we'll see what we can
get you
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
as you just heard on the countdown net
we had a hold called
at t minus 30 seconds prior to that the
countdown was proceeding nominally
keeping in mind that the purpose of the
countdown is to help us catch any
potential issues prior to flight
there are a thousand ways a launch can
go wrong and only one way
that it can go right given that we are
overly cautious
on the grounds uh and if the team or the
vehicle sees anything that looks even
just slightly off
they'll stop the countdown overall the
vehicle appears to be in good health
but that will be ending our launch
attempt for today
keep an eye out on our social media
accounts for the announcement of our
next launch opportunity
until then thanks for joining us and
we'll see you next time
[Music]